l'association créa passion a récemment
inauguré un espace artisanal à mare à
poule d'eau dans le cirque de salazie
on y trouve des créations entièrement
locale des produits du terroir des
accessoires de mode des tableaux de la
vaisselle et bien d'autres un seul mot
d'ordre pour cette association le made
in réunion sous toutes ses coutures
cette association elle est partie d'une
réunion de deux copines
parce qu'on voyait donc autour de nous
beaucoup de petites mains qui
travaillaient avec énergie efficacité
avec un imaginaire débordant et on se
disait mais pourquoi pas mettre en
évidence ou savoir faire donc à partir
de là on a créé notre association
il se trouve que toutes ces petites
mains sont devenus plutôt des
bienfaitrice et c'est le bouche à
oreille qui a fait venir toutes nos
adhérentes créatrice qui sont maintenant
des activ
ces délires donc sont artisanes et elle
travaille donc actuellement soit à
l'extérieur en exposition privée ou au
sein de notre association et entre de
notre espace artisanal que venons
d'ouvrir donc le 20 avril 2015 dans
cette boutique vous avez d'abord à
priori tous dès que des articles faits
main parce que nous protégeons
l'artisanat local
nous sommes des fervente justement
défendre is de cet artisanat que l'on
veut protéger
séverine fait partie des adhérents de
l'association
pour elle il est important de défendre
et valoriser l'artisanat local qui à ses
yeux est en train de se perdre
je fais toi la main le coeur à la base
il est brut donc je marque je mets trop
je fais le marquage tout ça ensuite je
le teint et jeu là semble donc que chez
les petits des petits sacs aussi sacs à
main pareil tout la couture et fait tout
le tressage est fait à la main
là il ya à peu près trois heures de
tressage vainqueur et une de tressage
alors je crains ce petit les feuilles
coco donc je fais des chapeaux en coco d
espagne et d'appareils trophée à la main
donc g13 quand ils sont verts ensuite je
les fais sécher et je les vernis pour
qu'ils sont un peu plus de résistance et
un petit peu plus de protection la
plupart des magasins tout ça ils vendent
ils vendent des choses qui viennent de
madagascar ou qui viennent d'ailleurs
donc quand même la réunion il ya
beaucoup d'artisanat ici donc c'est en
train de se perdre il faut chaud le
défendre l'espace artisanal de chréa
passion vient tout juste de voir le jour
pourtant la présidente de l'association
ne compte pas s'arrêter là et souhaite
concrétiser de nouveaux projets alors
nos projets à venir donc justement on
est en train d'y travailler
c'est de faire d'ouvrir cette parce que
c'est une ancienne école
là nous sommes installés à mare à poule
d'eau donc d'ouvrir cette école enfin un
espace extérieur vers le cirque de
salazie
dans un premier temps nous allons mettre
en place des ateliers pendant les
vacances
atelier de toutes sortes atelier poterie
atelier de recyclage atelier de tressage
atelier peinture pour faire venir les
adultes et les enfants dans cette dans
cet environnement qui vraiment adorable
ensuite on voudrait aussi on va là on y
réfléchit on va y travailler à partir de
la fin du mois de juin sur un marché de
noël dans l'enceinte de la cour
mais là ça va être un partenariat avec
la mairie de salazie donc nous notre
objectif c'est de faire venir énormément
de monde dans cette cour pour leur faire
vivre un maximum et surtout les gens du
cirque